it will be 34 years in April the
families of the 97 have grown used to
waiting and for what was described as a
burning Injustice they have now received
an apology
for the failings on that day but also
for the years of failings that followed
the lack of honesty that made the pain
and suffering all the worse policing is
apologizing and recognizing that placing
was the primary cause of the disaster
the Hillsborough disaster tragedy but
placing is also apologizing for the now
nearly 34 years that the families have
had to wait to have their questions
answered to have Justice to have some
form of closure about what happened on
that awful day
they've promised change to prevent a
repeat but the report calling for that
was published five years ago the delay
adding to the sense of Injustice for
families Louise Brooks lost her brother
Andrew Mark taking them 34 years to
apologize I don't think the report is
worth the paper it's printed on I think
um
it's just being one of those where
they've been seen in public to do what
they think they're expected to do but
there's no real sincerity
and those who investigated Hillsborough
say the continuing lack of a government
response is striking the government has
to accept
responsibility for appropriate reforms
that will deal at all levels with the
Berea those bereaved those who were
injured in such circumstances that to me
is absolutely essential only government
policy can actually write the wrongs of
the existing processes in within State
institutions in the Commons the Home
Secretary did offer this the government
remains absolutely committed to
responding to The Bishop's report as
soon as practicable but no indication of
when that will be the very fact the
Hillsborough families had to fight so
hard for so long to have their voices
heard to them is a sign of the systemic
failures that existed whether Future
Families in future tragedies are spared
that will be the test of what's being
promised now the the families say only a
Hillsborough law would prevent what they
see as the cover-up that prolonged their
Agony over those who went to the
football and never came home Greg Milam
Sky News Liverpool